le tours fc ne montera donc pas en nationale 3
après 2019, 2020 et 2021 nouveau veto hier soir
de la commission régionale de contrôle des clubs
comme un hamster dans sa roue les ciel et noir
sont donc une nouvelle fois condamnés à faire
du surplace malgré de bons résultats sportifs
ce soir la question même de la survie du
TFC est sur la table : audrey Champigny
les ciel et noir ont peut être joué la dernière
saison de leur histoire. Malgré une première
place au classement de régionale 1 cette saison,
le TFC ne montera pas en nationale 3. L'instance
régionale des clubs a rejeté le projet et les
garanties présentées par Jean-Marc Ettori. Entre
incompréhension et inquiétude le futur président
délégué du club est dans l'attente d'explications
concrètes : "c'est un relevé de conclusions d'une
réunion qu'on a reçu non daté ni signé. En tout
cas elle n'est officiellement pas valable
puisque on ne peut pas s'en servir même si
on voulait faire appel par exemple. Après elle
est quand même estampillée ligue du centre mais
on ne sait pas qui nous l'a réellement envoyée.
Une sanction qui pèse très lourd : balayées les
promesses de futurs actionnaires, balayés aussi
les 25 salariés de la SASP, coach, joueurs,
sans oublier l'association TFC en déséquilibre
financier. Une liquidation judiciaire serait
dramatique. C'est un scénario possible et le TFC
dans son ensemble puisque je rappelle aussi que
la structure SASP et l'association sont liées
inévitablement. Il y a quand même des factures
qui sont en attente de la part de l' ASCSP
vis-à-vis de l'association qui si jamais il
y avait une décision extrême de liquidation
inévitablement le liquidateur judiciaire
lui appellerait ces factures là, donc oui on est
sur des centaines de milliers d'euros. Jean-Marc
Ettori jettera t-il l'éponge ou fera-t-il
appel ?la réponse dans les prochains jours